teller I'm Neil Gaiman's and every year
world builders holds a giant auction
charity donation thing giving people
cool things and and raising an awful lot
of money for fantastic cause and every
year
I seem to be now reading a poem or a
book chosen by the people who pay money
to world builders and this year for
reasons known only to themselves they
have decided I need to read a grandpa's
ghastly gruesome dark and famous poem
The Raven
so I've licked a number of candles I
have fired up the fire I have found a
copy of the Oxford book of narrative
verse and I'm going to read it to you in
a comfortable chair by the fire as
befits a poem told in days of yore this
is the Raven
Once Upon a midnight dreary while I
pondered weak and weary over many a
quaint and curious volume of Forgotten
lore while I nodded nearly napping
suddenly there came a tapping as of
someone gently rapping rapping at my
chamber door to some visitor I muttered
tapping at my chamber door only this and
nothing more ah distinctly I remember it
was in the Bleak December and each
separate dying ember wrought its ghost
upon the floor eagerly I wished the
morrow vainly I had sought to borrow
from my books surcease of sorrow--sorrow
for the lost Lenore for the rare and
radiant maiden whom the angel's name
Lenore nameless here for evermore
and the silken sad uncertain rustling of
each purple curtain thrilled me filled
me with fantastic terrors never felt
before so that now to still the beating
of my heart I stood repeating tis some
visitor entreating entrance at my
chamber door some late visitor
entreating entrance at my chamber door
this it is and nothing more personally
my soul grew stronger hesitating then no
longer sir said I or madam truly your
forgiveness I implore
but the fact is I was napping and so
gently you came rapping and so faintly
you came tapping tapping at my chamber
door that I scarce was sure I heard you
here I opened wide the door darkness
there and nothing more deep into that
darkness peering long I stood there
wondering fearing doubting dreaming
dreams no mortal ever dared to dream
before but the silence was unbroken and
the stillness gave no token and the only
word there spoken was the whispered word
Lenore this I whispered
and an echo murmured back the word
Lenore merely this and nothing more back
into the chamber turning all my soul
within me burning soon again I heard a
tapping somewhat louder than before
surely said I surely that is something
at my window lattice let me see then
what thereat is and this mystery explore
let my heart be still a moment and this
mystery explore tis the wind and nothing
more open here I flung the shutter when
with many a flirt and flutter in there
stepped a stately Raven of the saintly
days of yore not the least obeisance
made he not a minute stopped or stayed
he but with mien of Lord Lord or lady
perched above my chamber door perched
upon a bust of Pallas just above my
chamber door perched and sat and nothing
more then this ebony bird beguiling my
sad fancy into smiling by the grave and
stern decorum of the countenance it wore
though thy crest be shorn and shaven
thou I said art sure no Craven ghastly
grim and ancient Raven wandering from
the nightly Shore tell me what thy
lordly name is on the night's Plutonian
Shore quoth the raven nevermore much i
marvelled this ungainly fowl to hear
discourse so plainly though its answer
little meaning--little relevancy bore
but we cannot help agreeing that no
living human being ever yet was blessed
with seeing bird above his chamber door
bird or beast upon the sculptured bust
above his chamber door with such name as
Nevermore but the Raven sitting lonely
on the Placid bust spoke only that one
word as if his soul in that one word he
did outpour nothing father then he
uttered not a feather then he fluttered
till I scarcely more than muttered other
friends have flown before on the morrow
he will leave me as my hopes have flown
before then
bird said Nevermore startled at the
stillness broken by reply so aptly
spoken doubtless said i what it utters
is its only stock and store caught from
some unhappy master whom unmerciful
disaster followed fast and followed
faster till his songs one burden bore
till the dirges of his hope that
melancholy burden bore of never
Nevermore that the Raven still beguiling
my sad fancy into smiling straight I
wheeled a cushioned seat in front of
bird and bust and door then upon the
velvet sinking like that took myself to
linking fancy unto fancy thinking what
this ominous bird of yore what this grim
ungainly ghastly gaunt and ominous bird
of yore meant in croaking Nevermore
their sigh sat engaged in guessing but
no syllable expressing to the fowl whose
fiery eyes now burned into my bosoms
core this and more i sat divining with
my head at ease reclining on the
cushions velvet lining that the
lamplight gloated or that whose velvet
violet lining with the lamplight
gloating o'er she shall press ah
Nevermore then we thought the air grew
denser perfumed from an unseen censer
swung by Seraphim whose footfalls
tinkled on the tufted floor wretch
I cried thy god hath lent thee by these
angels he hath sent thee respite respite
and Nepenthe from thy memories of lenore
quaff Oh quaff this kind Nepenthe and
forget this lost Lenore quoth the raven
nevermore
prophet said I thing of evil prophet
still if bird or devil whether tempter
sent or whether tempest tossed thee here
ashore desolate yet all undaunted on
this desert land enchanted on this home
by horror haunted tell me truly I
implore is there is there balm in Gilead
tell me tell me I implore quoth the
raven nevermore prophet said I thing of
evil prophet still if bird or devil by
that heaven that bends above us by that
God we both adore tell this soul with
sorrow laden if within the distant
aidenn it shall clasp a sainted maiden
whom the angels name lenore clasp a rare
and radiant maiden whom the angels name
lenore quoth the raven nevermore be that
word our sign of parting bird or fiend i
shrieked upstarting get thee back into
the tempest and the night's plutonian
shore leave no black plume as a token of
that lie thy soul hath spoken leave my
loneliness unbroken quit the bust above
my door take thy beak from out my heart
and take thy form from off my door quoth
the raven nevermore and the Raven never
flitting still is sitting still is
sitting on the pallid bust of Pallas
just above my chamber door and his eyes
have all the seeming of a demons that is
dreaming and the lamplight for him
streaming throws his shadow on the floor
and my soul from out that shadow that
lies floating on the floor shall be
lifted
Nevermore
and keep a listening support well
builders see you next year